Herr Rams lassen Sie uns zunächst auf
die aktuellen Ereignisse schauen die es
über Weihnachten gab wir haben gerade
das Video schon gezeigt die ukrainische
Luftwaffe hat ein russisches
Landungsschiff zerstört Russland
bestätigte lediglich den Angriff die
Ukraine hat das Manöver als großen Kuh
bezeichnet wie lautet Ihre Einschätzung
wie groß war dieser
Kuh also wenn es den Ukrainern und das S
nicht das erste Mal immer wieder gelingt
äh russische Schiffe in den Häfen auf
der Krim anzugreifen und auch zu
zerstören und ich erinnere dabei auch an
die moskv die ja vor gut anderthalb
Jahren durch die Ukraine versenkt worden
ist dann ist das schon ein Erfolg und
wir müssen das daran messen dass
Russland sich zu großen Teilen mit
seiner Flotte aus dem westlichen Teil
des Schwarzen Meeres zurückgezogen hat
mit der Zerstörung eines
landungsschiffes geht zwei Fähigkeiten
verloren a militärische Güter
entsprechend zu transportieren oder auch
irgendwo seelandungen durchzuführen was
die Russen ja offensichtlich zu Anfang
des Krieges in der Nähe von Odessa mal
vorgehabt haben das hat hat sich damit
dann endgültig zerschlagen mhm wir
wollen auf das endende Kriegsjahr heute
zurückblicken Herr Rams und seit dem
Herbst kann man sagen vor allem im Fokus
auch als Zentrum des Krieges kann man
sagen die Ost und Südukraine
vor allem die Stadt avdfka seit dem
Herbst hart umkämpft vor ein paar Tagen
gab es dann die Meldung dass die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte die zerstörte
Kleinstadt Marinka aufgegeben haben wie
prikär schätzen Sie aktuell die Lage in
der Ostukraine
ein also in der OST Ukraine sieht das so
aus dass die Russen ich sag mal über das
ganze zurückliegende Jahr immer wieder
Verstärkung dorthinebracht haben
zeitweil ich hier und auch in anderen
Bereichen der Ukraine sogenannte
Elitetruppen beispielsweise
Luftlandetruppen und dergleichen
die Russen haben mit diesen Truppen den
Erfolg den man sich erhofft hatte
nämlich zumindest die oblasten lchansk
und donjz komplett in die Hände zu
bekommen bisher nicht durchsetzen können
sondern die Ukrainer haben auch badwinka
sehr nachhaltig verteidigt sie achten
dar drauf dass die Verluste nicht so
hoch sind und es gibt die eine oder
andere Information darüber dass ich sage
mal ukrainische Soldaten in Zug und
Kompaniestärke sich gegen Bataillon und
Regiment da zur Wehr gesetzt haben das
zeigt so ein bisschen die Situation
trotzdem glaube ich dass der ukrainische
Generalstab richtig entscheidet wenn er
dann bestimmte Ortschaften aufgibt bevor
die eigenen Verluste zu groß werden so
ein bisschen prägend für die erste
Jahreshälfte war ja die ukrainische
Gegenoffensive lange wurde spekuliert
dann irgendwann fand Stadt es ging
langsamer für die ukrainischen Truppen
voran als gedacht warum ist die
ukrainische Großoffensive die es dann so
im Frühjahr Sommer gab nicht so stark
angekommen wie man sich das erhofft oder
gedacht
hatte ich glaube dass das zwei Gründe
hat der eine Grund ist der dass die
Russen in diesen Bereichen sehr intensiv
verteidigungsstellen Stellungen in
mehreren Linien ausgebaut haben und dass
es in diesem Bereichen sehr große
Minenfelder gegeben hat mit denen die
Ukraine offensichtlich nicht gerechnet
hat und wo es ausgesprochen schwierig
gewesen ist diese Minenfelder zu
durchdringen um auf die zweite oder
dritte stellungsreihe der russischen
Kräfte angreifen zu können
ich sag mal der Durchbruch den man sich
möglicherweise erhofft hat ist nirgendwo
passiert von DAH ist das dann irgendwann
in vielen Bereichen zu Stellungskriegen
übergegangen die von der Ukraine
durchaus geschickt geführt worden sind
die aber die erwarteten Erfolge nicht
gebracht haben vielleicht war auch der
Begriff
Großoffensive etwas zu positiv angelegt
und von der Erwartungshaltung der
westlichen Seite inklusiv westlicher
Militärs vielleicht etwas zu hoch
angesetzt
worden es gibt weitere Gründe dafür die
Ukraine hat ja keine eigene
Waffenproduktion auch wenn sie jetzt
Rüstungsfirmen aufbaut um selber Waffen
in bestimmten Bereichen bestimmten
Systemen zu produzieren heißt das immer
noch nicht dass diese Waffen sofort
verfügbar sind das ist der eine Teil
dabei und der zweite Teil den wir immer
wieder in Erinnerung rufen müssen ist
die Tatsache die ukreinees in all diesen
Fr Fragen der militärischen Hilfe vom
Westen abhängig das fängt mit der
Munition an wo wie wir ja alle wissen
die Europäische Union eine Million
Schuss bis zum Ende diesen Jahres
zugesagt hatte und wo wir jetzt irgendwo
zwischen 300 und 400 000 liegen mit der
Lieferung und die Lieferung von ich sage
mal rund 600.000 Schuss noch in den
letzten drei Tagen diesen Jahres dürfte
ausgesprochen unwahrscheinlich sein das
heißt man musste aufpassen was man
verspricht und was man hinter erhalten
kann und man sollte auch dann auch der
westlichen Hemisphäre bei der
Bevölkerung oder bei den Militärs mit
solchen Versprechungen keine falschen
Erwartungen wecken das ist ein Problem
die Ukraine ich hätte das gerne gesehen
wenn Sie mehr Erfolge gehabt hätten und
beispielsweise im Süden Richtung
militopol hätte durchstoßen können es
ist hier verwerrt geblieben das heißt
der Krieg zwischen Russland und der
Ukraine die Aggression Russlands und die
Verteidigung der Ukraine geht in ein
weiteres Jahr den wirkmen erste Fragen
unserer Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer
rein Herr Rams ich stell gerne leite das
gerne an Sie weiter ein Zuschauer fragt
was bringen denn solche Offensive
Offensive Nadelstiche wie das jetzt
jüngst über Weihnachten der Fall war mit
dem Landungsschiff der Ukraine ohne
wirkliche
Großoffensive also ich glaube man kann
wirklich sagen dass jeder auch noch so
kleiner Erfolg eine Rolle spielt mit
Blick auf die Moral der ukrainischen
Soldaten und der ukrainischen
Bevölkerung und dass jeder nadelsticht
in die Ukraine den Russen versetzt den
Russen auch weh tut das gilt sowohl für
seestreitk als auch für Luftstreitkräfte
es gibt ja hier die Informationen dass
drei relativ moderne Jagdbomber der
Russen in den letzten Tagen von der
Ukraine abgeschossen worden sind das
sind Kleinigkeiten auf den Blick aber
diese Verluste summieren sich im Laufe
der Zeit auf und durch diese
aufsimierung verliert dann
möglicherweise Russland in bestimmten
Bereichen ich sprach gerade von dem
westlichen Schwarzen Meer bestimmte
Fähigkeiten um diesen Krieg erfolgreich
weiterführen zu können es wäre gut
gewesen wenn die wenn es der Ukraine mit
mit einer Offensive gelungen wäre
beispielsweise über militopol bis zum
Asowschen Meer vorzustoßen um auf diese
Art und Weise die Krim abzuschneiden
denn das ist ein dann ein Ereignis was
möglicherweise auf vielen kleinen
Ereignissen beroht dann aber auch eine
entsprechende Wirkung erreicht und um
diese Wirkung muss es gehen
beispielsweise auch um den Präsidenten
Putin vielleicht dann doch noch mal
davon zu überzeugen dass Verhandlung
vielleicht nicht so schlecht werden mhm
wir wollen ja heute gleichzeitig auch
vorausschauen auf das neue Jahr 204 20
was glauben sie wird es noch mal eine
neue Großoffensive der Ukraine alsbald
geben und falls ja wann wäre da ein
günstiger
Zeitpunkt also Herr Bürgermeister ich
habe nach wie vor keine Glaskugel von
daher mit aller Vorsicht und ohne zu
spekulieren ich gehe davon aus dass die
Ukraine neue Verbände aufstellen wird
oder die verandenden Verbände
entsprechend auffrischen wird diese
Verbände müssen entsprechend ausgebildet
werden dabei unterstützen wir ja die
bundeswehrbildde zum Ende bis zum Ende
diesen Jahres 10.000 ukrainische
Soldaten aus das ist auch eine Zahl die
gehalten wird
die Ukraine braucht es weiteren
entsprechende Waffensysteme sie braucht
die Waffensysteme Stichwort
Luftüberlegenheit der Russen
insbesondere im Bereich der Flugabwehr
und der Luftverteidigung dort sind neue
Waffensysteme angekündigt und ich hoffe
dass diese Waffensysteme möglich schnell
kommen damit die Luftüberlegenheit der
Russen
entsprechend abgebaut und gemindert
werden kann und die Ukraine auch in
diesem Bereich entsprechend Aktionen
ergreifen kann und ein ganz wichtiger
Punkt ist der der Westen muss liefern ob
das den künftig die F16 Flugzeuge sind
die möglicherweise mit ersten Teilen im
ersten Quartal ausgeliefert werden die
Pilotenausbildung findet statt oder ob
das Kampfpanzer und Schützenpanzer und
tilleriesysteme und vor allen Dingen
auch Munition ich sprach die Munition ja
gerade schon mal an es ist ungeheuer
wichtig dass die Ukraine über die
entsprechende Munition verfügt denn wir
können immer noch davon ausgehen dass
die Russen be beispielsweise bei
artillerieffeuer etwa die ich sage mal
achtfache bis zehnfache Menge an
Munition pro Tag verfeuert die die
Ukraine einfach nicht hat und darauf
entsprechend adäquat antworten zu können
Waffen Munition Material ist das eines
haben sie gerade angesprochen da wollen
wir auch gleich noch einmal konkreter
draufschauen was das neue Jahr da
bringen könnte für die Ukraine
Mannstärke ist allerdings das andere
unser Zuschauer Alex fragt hat die
Ukraine überhaupt genug Männer um noch
zu
gewinnen
also das diese Frage würde ich eindeutig
mit Ja beantworten die Ukraine hat
weniger deutlich weniger Verluste als
die russische Seite das ist eine
Feststellung die kann man aus
verschiedensten Nachrichtenquellen kann
man die belegen
zweite Aussage die Ukraine verfügt
aufgrund ihrer Einwohnerzahlen über
hinreichen Männer aber trotzdem müssen
einem natürlich die Aktivitäten die
jetzt zum Teil begangen werden nämlich
dass man das whrpflichtigen Alter auf
dem Bereich ich sag mal von 18 bis 60
Jahren ausdehnt oder 25 bis 60 Jahren
ausehen das bedeutet schon dass mehr
Soldaten gezogen werden können dazu
kommt die Maßnahme dass alle in dieser
Altersgruppe sich bei den entsprechenden
Behörden registrieren lassen müssen um
praktisch erfasst zu werden damit die
Ukraine selber weiß auf wen und auf wie
viele Soldaten sie zurückgreifen kann
das ist ein wichtiger ein wichtiger
Schritt der der Ukraine dann
möglicherweise auch weitere Kapazitäten
schafft von daher ich würde noch nicht
von personalen not reden aber richtig
ist das Personal ein kritischer Faktor
ist der entsprechend von der ukreine
behandelt und gehändelt werden muss um
die entsprechende Anzahl von Soldaten
zur Verfügung zu haben um gegen die
ständigen Verstärkung der russischen
Seite entsprechend erfolgreich kämpfen
zu können